>>Lora: In Cleveland's
metropolitan school district,
four out of ten high school
students don't graduate.
>>But there's one school where
ninety-five percent graduate
and eighty-four percent
of those go to college.
>>Lilly: We get mentors
and real world experience
through volunteering and internships.
>>Y'von: And when we graduate, we're
prepared to succeed in college,
in our careers and in life.
>>Lora: It's called M C
Squared STEM High School.
Take a look at what they
do for their students.
It might change what
you do for yours.
>>Gary: I think when we look
at a program like STEM School,
they've laid out a very good program.
The hands-on projects, the
industrial collaboration,
the university collaboration,
is a wonderful environment
in which the kids can excel.
Each kid has to have their fuse
lit for that rocket to take off.
So you can get them out
on the launching pad,
but if you don't light the
fuse, they're not gonna go.
>>Tim and I started out
mentoring about a year and a half,
almost two years ago, when
he was entering sophomore.
He has become a tremendously
different person.
He's now a very confident young man.
This is really remarkable.
We brought kids in from the
neighborhood, basically--
they're not handpicked from
premium high schools in the area--
and gave them a rich experience
in working with role models.
>>Tim: What's rewarding about
working with professionals here
on GE campus is getting
to know how their life is.
It makes me think at least that, you
know, hey, if I go into this career,
that's gonna be me, you know.
That's gonna be me
working really hard.
That's gonna be me using all these
math that my math teacher's me.
That's gonna be me
using all the science
that my science teacher's
teaching me.
>>Gary: This real world experience
that they get really grounds them,
so school is no longer for
them a theoretical hypothesis
for what life might be like.
>>Teacher: We're gonna be
working with multi-meters.
Okay, so your training is
actually on equipment today.
>>Gary: So it's very reality based.
>>Teacher: Okay, what does
that K mean, by the way?
>>Thousand, kilo, thousand.
>>Tim: Thousand means K.
>>Teacher: Okay, so
that's two thousand--
>>Tim: So, since we're
at two thousand K ohms...
>>They're teaching us from experience
and when the professionals come in,
it's like, wow, I need
to pay attention.
>>Mastery based grading is
different from the ABC scale.
We get graded on M which is mastery.
Reaching mastery and incomplete.
>>Catherine: It's a negative slope
and it's less than or equal to--
>>Assessment in mastery
in math is done two ways.
One, through the testing of the
mastery of the paper pencil skills,
but then any project
we do has a rubric.
So the students know
exactly what they need to do
to perform to reach mastery.
>>Before we did the quadratic
formula, what did we do?
>>The kids have to show that
they've learned the content,
and I feel really comfortable
about that.
>>Lilly: Every summer
in our three week break,
I've gotten the chance
to do an internship.
>>When I came to STEM, I
wanted to be an astronomer,
so I got my NASA internship,
and I build hydrogen sensors
for the International Space Station,
but I found out I don't
want to be an astronomer.
My second was in the
injury prevention center
at University Hospitals.
I found out, I don't
wanna do anything
that has to do with hospitals.
My third one, which is the
one I'm currently in is
at American Civil Liberties Union.
I think I'm gonna end up doing
something with political science
that has to do with
protection of our rights,
'cause I'm very passionate
about that.
>>Y'von: Engineering is in my family.
My father was a building
engineer for Cleveland Thermal,
so I was always interested,
but I needed guidance
going into high school.
At STEM, everything was based
on projects with other people,
not just science, technology,
engineering and mathematics.
It goes beyond that.
It goes to character, teamwork.
At my internship, my main
duty is document control.
I started in March
and maybe around July,
I started to understand
the stuff I was folding.
the stuff I was typing.
This internship is more school
to me than high school right now.
>>Student: Science
and math, pretty much.
>>Jeff: Okay.
>>We should talk about,
instead of coming back here
for your other classes, maybe going
to health careers like
Melissa's doing.
>>Gary: They're not only getting from
us an insight into, how do you get
through high school to
prepare for college?
How do you choose in college?
But, what does it look
like beyond that?
What are you really
getting ready for?
So the message to the kids is, it's
not a linear path through school
or grad school or med
school or law school.
It's really that emotional guidance.
What are you feeling in here
that makes sense to you in life
where you think you can contribute?
That emotional guidance
I think is really key.